hello everyone and welcome to game 10 of
the world church championship match 2021
it's magnus carlson versus yanipanishi
and currently the situation in the match
does not look well for yan he is down by
three points and he has five games up
until game 14 to bonds back in the match
uh otherwise uh well it's uh not gonna
be possible for him to do anything about
it uh even if he manages to equalize it
it's still not enough he still has to go
into tie breaks but uh
uh i believe magnus lost three games all
together in all of his world chess
championship matches so you know uh
losing three games now would be
and
a very impressive undertaking um uh for
from jan
uh but you know it's not impossible so
here magnus has the white pieces and
will nipple try to you know calm things
down as he just lost to two very
tough games first blundering upon them
blundering the piece or will we try to
go for the win with the black pieces and
try and win at any cost but before we
check out the game here we do have a
couple of nice photos so let's enjoy
that so here uh we have the handshake of
course um a lot can be seen in this chat
handshake you can see that magnus is
it's almost as if uh he's sorry for the
current situation that jan put himself
in in the match and he
kind of maybe feels that it'd be better
if it was still very intense and that
they were fighting it out until the end
uh but all in all uh well he he just
wants to win and uh uh you know keep his
world chase championship title and jan
you can see that he's already looking at
the board so he could be uh very very
eager to to get back um
to the chess and you know skip all of
these formalities and here we have the
first move the first move was made by
amnal kuwaisi she's the uh i believe
first
female emirati formula three driver uh
so she she's making the the first move
you can see that she's taking it very
seriously maurice uh behind enjoying
himself as usual uh the the the players
you know that they are very eager to
start the game uh and here you can see
just uh how uh jan is approaching this
uh the uh petra of defense is on the
board uh you can see that he just played
knight to f6 and he's trying to get any
reaction whatsoever from magnus and
magnus you know not he's a statue he's
not giving away anything you can see
that he's exploding exposing some of his
chest hair it could be sort of a
an attempt of asserting dominance but it
could also be uh you know that the the
shirt just moved so yeah these are of
course only my interpretation of the
photos they could also be just photos uh
that being said uh let's check out the
game magnus with the white pieces opens
with e4 we have e5 by on uh knight to f3
and again knight to f6 we have the
petrov defense and in game eight we've
had the d4 line but now nipple repeats
knight captures uh sorry magnus repeats
knight captures on e5 like he did in
game four so here we have d6 and now uh
knight back to d3 if you remember in
game four knight to f3 was played but
here magnus goes for knight to d3 uh
it's the famous game uh magnus crossing
versus fabiana caruana from the 2018
world championship match in london the
one that magnus almost lost well he was
you know in a pretty bad position but
that's what magnus decided to
uh play and obviously he prepared
something much better than what he
played against caruana so here we have
knight captures on e4 uh the same as in
the game against caruana queen to e2
queen to e7 and now knight to f4
and here uh fabi just played knight to
c6 but here we have knight to f6 just
returning that knight offering a queen
trade and magnus plays uh uh d4 and now
what do you play here the position has
been reached before and many moves have
been played here queen captures an e2 uh
with czech bishop g4 attacking the queen
bishop to f5 also g5 is the known move
here but the move that diane plays is a
new move he plays knights to c6 and this
is an invitation to a very very complex
game and magnus really took his time
here to decide how to how to continue uh
uh this position because uh if this was
just a normal game and magnus had this
position of course you don't really
think twice you play bishop to e3 and
after something like bishop to f5 knight
to c3 and we'd probably see both player
players castling queenside and we would
have this position and this could get
very very ugly for for both of them uh
all in all you know it's it's it's a
it's a very uh complicated game uh for
for both of them from this point on but
magnus says uh all right this is a
wheelchair championship match
i'm already leading by three points so
there's no need to do anything this
double edged let's just play c3 the
queen trade is still on the board so you
know if jan wants to capture i would be
very happy to develop my pieces we have
d5 by on knight to d2 uh and now comes
knight to d8 uh preparing uh to move the
c pawn also the knight can be shifted to
e6 uh we have knights to f3 and now
comes queen capture sunny to young
trades queens because here uh even queen
to e5 is a very interesting move the
queen will be very nicely centralized
here and then if you if you trade then
maybe even knight captures an e5 also d
captures an e5 could be very unpleasant
so here we have a queen trade bishop
captures an e2 and now bishop to d6 so
the queens are of the board
and both players castle so castles
castles and now bishop to d3 it's gonna
be much more useful on this diagonal
rook to e8 and now rook to e1 offering a
queen trade we have captures captures
and now knight to e6 so offering a trade
of knights and magnus has to decide
whether to trade or or to go back he of
course trades knight captures an e6 we
have bishop captures on e6 you could
also consider f captures this does
improve your uh situation in the center
but uh it you know it's not all that
much you will still need to do something
about this pawn at some point you will
have to push it to develop your bishop
so maybe not all that impressive so
instead we have bishop captures on e6 g3
by magnus now maybe even considering
knight the knights the g2 to gain
control of the f4 square so you can
develop the bishop g6 bion knights the
g2 and now rook to e8 so nipple nicely
developed magnus still needs to bring
his bishop and the rook into the game so
f3 uh controlling the the knight very
nicely uh and now knight to h5 uh we
have king to f2 and now c6 so black's
position is very very solid uh but uh
that's pretty much all there is to it we
have g4 now asking what do you do with
the knight nipple goes back knight to g7
with some f5 ideas in the future and
bishop to f4 so just trading everything
off the board we have bishop captures
knight captures and now g5 so now the
knight has to move and at some point
nipple will strike with f5 and now
magnus needs to decide whether to go for
knight captures an e6 or to go back with
knight to e2 knight captures an e6 is
very interesting
because although the material is equal
here here is a is an opportunity
basically to uh you know uh introduce
some imbalance into the position because
uh we have everything the same one rook
one light square bishop one night but
here if you trade knight for a bishop
then it's a pretty much a completely
different end game because now after
knight captures uh it's a bishop against
the knight and let's say rook to e1 now
okay you can't move the knight the rook
would hang let's say h6 we defend the
pawn bishop to f5 attack the knight
twice and now knight g7 we trade rooks
of the board and this is probably the
end game we would get where we would
have a bishop against the night uh the
game is on both sides of the board so
this tends to favor the bishop but
you know as i always say knights are
tricky bastards uh and
magnus does not uh
want to play this against ian so instead
he just goes back knights to e2 uh and
now we have f5 s planned uh so now there
are a lot of pressure here and magnus
has to decide how to how to go about
this uh the situation on the clock is uh
magnus has an hour where asean has an
hour and a half so yeah i'm playing very
very quickly uh we have h3 uh defending
the g for pawn and now king to f7 we
have rook to h1 now magnus has some
ideas of maybe h4 opening up the h file
and h6 we have f for now just trading
everything off f captures in g4 we have
h captures and the bishop captures
but now of course rook captures an h6
and now you have to be careful you can't
just grab a pawn here if you do this
bishop g6 check will pick up the rook
and then you you win the game so instead
after rook captures an h6 we have bishop
to f5 we counter the light square bishop
bishop captures an f5 knight captures on
f5 and now rook the h7 checks so luckily
uh nipple can go back with the knight so
you don't have to lose any pawns and now
f captures on g5 magnus is up a pawn but
again only temporarily so king the g6
attacks the rook and the g5 pawn rook
back to h3 and now king captures and g5
uh we have rooked the g3 check king f6
rook to f3 check king to e7 and now
knight to f4 now the knight is coming to
g6 then to e5 and the knight will have
an excellent outpost here but it's not
all that impressive because this knight
can also have an excellent outpost on e4
because if you look at the pawn
structure it's identical and uh well uh
you don't hope to
get anything out of this so king the d6
we have knights to g6 rook to e6 by
nipple and not knight to e5 we have
knight to e8 um of course nipple knows
what carlson's next move is so here we
have a rook to f7 and okay a lot of
things can happen here if you never play
something like a6 then rook to d7 will
be checkmate but of course that's why
nepal played knight to the e8 he played
it so he can play rook to f6 check and
force a rook trade here rook captures on
f6 was played knight captures an f6 and
here king to e3 this move 41 time
control has been reached and the players
are allowed to draw the game
after move 40. so he was in this
position on move 41 that magnus and nepo
agreed to a draw as there is nothing
more uh to be done here so uh still
three wins for magnus and seven draws uh
we'll see what happens in the next one
there are four more games in the world
chess championship match and if nipple
can get three wins out of those four
games we are going into tie breaks
otherwise that will not be happening
so uh
this was uh the this was a fine game if
uh if the situation was you know uh
if nine games up until this point ended
in a draw but since magnus is leading by
three points this doesn't really help
you on all that much but okay he had the
black pieces here so of course he he
wants to stabilize he doesn't want to
lose another game and tomorrow or i
don't know if they play tomorrow if it's
a rest day but on game 11 he will have
to strike with the white pieces but not
only that if he wants to get back into
this match he will also have to win at
least one game with the black pieces
uh so
not another pleasant position to be in
but he he did play this game very very
solidly and he even uh allowed uh for
this position if you remember in the
opening d for knight to c6 if magnus was
feeling ambitious if he wanted to play
bishop to e3 then we would see that both
player players castle in queen side
position and then it would be a very
very hard fought game of course but
magnus as there's really no point in
going into that uh just simplified and
and that's it of course after king e3
they agreed to a draw uh so yeah uh
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh wheelchair championship game 10. uh
we'll see what happens in the next four
games uh i would like to thank ardell
and chagoli uh scott christensen varun
kumar johan bridger and robert arathun
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing uh the
coverage of the world chess championship
uh until it ends uh so thank you i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day